(sirène)
- Ces images publiées
sur les réseaux soréseaux sociax
montrent la voiture de
Daria Douguine en flammes.
Selon les premières
informations, une bombe aurait
été placée dans le VUS que
conduisait la femme de 29 ans.
Sa mort a été constatée
sur place. Mais c'est plutôt
son père, Alexandre Douguine,
un proche du président russe
Vladimir Poutine, qui aurait
été visé attaque.
Philosophe et ultranationaliste,
c'est un ardent défenseur du
monde russe, une idéologie qui
met l'accent sur la restauration
du pouvoir de la Russie.
Souvent surnommé "le cerveau
on russe en Ukraine.
PAUL GOGO, collaboration
spéciale en Russie
- Il milite depuis des années
pour que l'Ukraine soit
détruite que l'Ukraine
revient dans le giron de
la Russie. Et sa fille a un peu
prie le relais de
elle a été très présente
dans les "talk shows",
les émissions de télévision
mes théories.
- Le père et la fille venaient
de participer à un festival
culturel et devaie
Alexandre Douguine aurait
toutefois décidé de prendre
la route seul.
Une enquête pour homicide
est en cours afin ours afin oure
la lumière sur cet attentat.
En période de guerre, l'Ukraine
nie toutefois toute implicat
depuis bientôt
six mois. Kiev craint davantage
de bombardements d
les jours à venir, à l'heure
où l'Ukraine fêtera le jour
de son indépendance l'inquiétude
autour de la centrale nucléaire
de Zaporijia, la plus grande
d'Europe, toujours occupée
par l'armée russe.
La recrudescence des combats
autour de cette centrale
fait resurgir le spectre
d'une catastrophe pire que
celle de Tchernobyl.
Dirigeants américains,
français, allemands et
britanniques ont d'ailleurs
Ici Dano,
Radio-Canada, Mon